so let's look at a few other refinements
we can make for starters I think it's
pretty lame that we've gone through all
this work to sign the user in and all we
say is welcome player you know or we
know our user signed in we should talk
to him or her by name so let's do that
now what we're going to do here is go
into my intro view controller and where
we say refresh interface based on sign
in instead of saying welcome player
we're going to get that information from
the Google Play game service so what
we're going to do here is we're going to
say self dot sign in label that text
equals and a string string with format
welcome object to be named later and if
you've either started browsing through
our reference documentation or just kind
of fooling around with code hinting
maybe you've noticed that through the
gpg manager shared instance we can get
this thing called the application model
and this starts to contain some
interesting information about the
application one thing it contains is
this property called player which has
another property I think the only thing
associated with it right now called
local player that has a name so let's
see what happens when we run this oh we
get welcome no that's not right so
what's going on here well what happens
is when you sign into google play games
the Google Play game service and start
fetching information that it thinks
you're going to need like information
about the player definitions for all
your achievements the players progress
towards completing those achievements
and so on however since we're trying to
say hello to the player immediately
after sign it is complete the service
hasn't had enough time yet to go out and
get all that information or at least
confirm that the cache information it
has is still up to date so how do we fix
this well one way might be to add a
timer so that
seconds later we say hello to the player
but there's a more elegant way of doing
it that the service provides for us so
instead of setting the text right away
I'm going to do this I'm going to call
the gpg manager shared instance and I'm
going to access the application model
and within the application model i'm
going to call this method load data for
key with a completion handler now the
key here is and this is just a constant
that we define gpg model and you can see
it down here local player key and for
our completion handler let's indent that
a bit now we can look and say well if
there was no error set self dot sign and
label text equals and a string string
with format welcome object and then we
can call gpg manager shared instance
application model dot player local
player named who now this time when we
run the application we get back a
personalized message that says welcome
with my name by the way there's also
another method called reload data for
key now this method works almost the
same as low data for key I believe the
difference is that reload a tofurkey
tells the service I want you to ignore
any cached data you have go out on the
net and actually grab any new
information whereas load data for Key
says if you have cash information it's
okay to use it so I think if we run this
you might see a slightly longer delay in
between when you sign the sign up button
appears and the welcome Todd Kerpelman
message appears and I believe that's
because I'm making an extra force
network called I didn't necessarily have
to make
so we're going to switch this back to
load data for key finally I'm going to
show you one other problem that we might
want to fix now I've got a pretty good
internet connection as it turns out
google's got internet go figure but
watch what happens when we run this
you're going to see for a brief moment
that the g plus sign in button is still
there it takes a moment for the service
to sign me in and make the Sign In
button go away and certainly when I'm
out in the real world on a 3g network or
something that delay could be much
longer and you don't want your user
repeatedly clicking that sign-in button
thinking that you know for some reason
they're just not getting signed in so
what we want to do is when we get to
that moment where we're trying silent
authentication we want to let the user
know hey we're trying to sign you as in
the background please be patient for a
minute and we can do that by looking at
the value that gets returned by try
silent on the authentication now this
actually returns a boolean and this
boolean is yes if the system has
determined that it is going to try and
silently authenticate the user it says
looks like there's an old o auth token
here I'm going to try and sign the user
in so we can take advantage of that
first thing we're going to do is create
a low property here not atomic school
that is trying the silent sign in and
then down here i'm going to say self
trying silent sign in is equal to the
value that gets returned and remember
this gets returned immediately by the
try silent authentication method and
then we can go back up to our refresh
interface based on sign in method and
we're going to go up here and say self
dot sign in button dot enabled equals
not self trying silent sign in so if we
get to this point the user is not signed
in yet but the system is attempting to
sign them in you will see the sign in
button visible but it will not be
enabled similarly if the user is not
signed in yet and silent authentication
has failed or the system says I don't
think this person's logged in before or
just wasn't able to silently sign the
user in the Sign In button will be
visible and it will be enabled there's
one other thing I forgot to do which is
here under finish with off we get to
this point once the attempt to silently
sign the user in is finished so we can
say self dot trying silent sign in is
equal to no alright so now let's run
this and you should see that that
sign-in button was visible but disabled
for that brief moment in between signing
in and when the sign up button appeared
now I'm going to sign out and it looks
like the Sign In button is there and is
once again enabled I'm going to click it
i'm going to say except go back into the
game and there we go we're signed in we
have a nice sign up button that again we
could probably hide the menu somewhere
and the game is addressing me by name I
feel like we're friends already so at
this point we're pretty much done with
the section on getting the user signed
in from here it's it's the fun stuff we
get to now add achievements we get to
add leaderboards we can share our game
play with a friend that kind of stuff
now that we've gone through all the hard
work of getting the user signed in let's
start having some fun and we're going to
do that in the next chapter so I'll see
you in a few days thanks
baba
ha